hi guys Greg here I'm going to be doing
a review of episode 9 at season 7 of The
Walking Dead I don't have cable so I
have to run it off amazon today what a
great episode before I get into it they
wanted to give a couple of shout outs
wanted to give a shut up to the
eaglemoss collections who has this
Walking Dead collectors model series as
you can see here you got Rick and Daryl
Rick they are all that's right guys if
you're a collector and a big fan of The
Walking Dead you're probably going to
want to check these guys out each month
eaglemoss will send you a collector's
model based on one of your favorite
characters from the show starts just for
95 plus shipping the first package
you'll get Rick a collector's character
booklet and an overall guide to the
collection then after that you'll get
two new characters and character
booklets as well each month with your
continuous description of 1795 a month
that's actually a discount of the retail
price shipping is that one 95 they have
other special gifts and goodies as well
for later packages and they are
officially approved by AMC it's a great
way to get your collection starter
there's a link of the description box
and the other one on and give a quick
shout out to our these guys at p no evil
they have this shirt right here they
sent gianna shirt as well he's not with
me in the video today he will be rocking
that shirt in an upcoming video I mean
come on we go [ __ ] cool this shirt is
and his toys are cool but the shirts
really cool to Tino evil is run by these
independent artist Francis t and his
brother Franco every one of their shirts
is designed and printed in house to
assure top-notch quality and I'll do a
t-shirt like it's soft and comfortable
and then they feature some like really
killer design which you can see more of
at T no evil calm now when up unpaid
shout out there's just really cool
products that they sent over and I was
like hell yeah I'll show you guys out
this is some cool [ __ ] so rocking the
road The Walking Dead I feel is back in
form baby I loved I loved everything
about this episode like the first half
of season 7 was like devastation mode I
mean starts off of the death of Abraham
and Glenn as we all know and as the
season progresses our characters become
even more distant and more detached
whenever we see Darrell he's a slave in
Egan's community Maggie and Sasha are
hiding out of
Carol is doing her Carol thing go stay
away from me Morgan is now with Ezekiel
people at the king dummies were way from
Alexandria and worst of all rick is just
not being Rick he's acting purely out of
here so rendering his strengths and
Meegan's will and I did feel some of
what a lot of people were complaining
about the walking dead had become the
negan show our characters weren't
together they're all separated for the
most part they were becoming rather a
weak-minded and then long the way
Spencer and Olivia were kill which is
real bummer I love the way the first
half of season 7 ended with the
remaining core members coming back
together ready to fight me again it
wasn't so the last scene of episode 8
where I realized how great season 7 it
already is that wasn't too sure what
direction the show was going and I
didn't like what had become of the
characters I love so much because I want
them only get back to who they were as a
group which is a great intentional
effect of the show the first half of
season 7 is negan not to you know
killing people he's also just tear it
apart their souls but in this episode it
does give you that feeling of our heroes
are on the rise in this episode we start
off with father Gabriel he's jacking all
the supplies in Alexandria he puts them
in a car and drives off in the middle of
the night it's a smart opening because
the first half of this season was really
a lot about losing hope and even though
it ended on a hopeful note the second
half of the season starts off in a way
we're left wondering if the character
who started off very cowardly who grew
to become courageous is now going back
to his cowardly ways aka losing hope to
me this episode is all about the tug and
pool of feelings of hope and then
feelings of not having hope then we see
you Rick and his group speaking with
Gregory at the hilltop name's Gregory to
was in the news of course given the
usual [ __ ] in his cowardly ways how
he's not going to help out going back to
the loss of hope and then immediately
answered in system hope again because
there's this very touching moment where
the people of the hilltop who are not
really skilled fighters I think a lot of
them I think most of them aren't
fighters at all gather together to tell
Rick and primarily Maggie that that are
willing to learn to fight and the first
half of the season we only saw King
Ezekiel one time which I know was a
bummer for a lot of people because he's
such a big part of the comic books yeah
I say the dynamics of all of his scenes
now feel different and feel actually
more authentic weirdly knowing that he's
being on a voice and he's putting on an
act as they revealed in his episode
where this is all uh you know saw that
he's putting on that if he acts like a
king people will have hope Jesus then
takes Rick's trip to the kingdom to meet
Ezekiel where they're greeted by Richard
who's this guard that breathes heavy
like them and in what seems I see a
minute I don't know I'm the only one who
notices be kind of breathes a little
heavy but I do like that character
something tells me he's going to be one
of the characters that dies in the few
episodes but I really do feel this man's
motivation and I think the actor does a
great job of playing someone who
possesses strength but at the end of the
day surrenders the hierarchy he's like a
true soldier to a king but there's this
scene when Morgan reunites with Rick
it's very touching moment as well when
asked how Ricky Morgan know each other
Rick simply says that they know each
other from the start and it's just this
great moment of history between the two
Morgan like comes and goes a lot but
he's been around since the first season
technically and no matter how often they
get separated they always come back
together I love a good debate scene and
the scene when Ezekiel and Rick are
negotiating over whether or not Ezekiel
should help out Rick in his quest to
take down negan is a really really well
done thing I just got to say the dude
who speaks for zekiel jerry's that asian
guy [ __ ] hilarious the witnessed
scene plays out is great because it
really does bounce back and forth
between hope that ezekiel will help and
then uh no maybe he oh maybe he'll I
don't think he will like in that scene
when Maureen says they shouldn't kill it
was a rare moment where I really
understood Morgan's reasoning for not
killing because normally i'm just
annoyed when he's talking about it he
knows is that if they fight yes
survivors will die they could possibly
win but most likely people on their side
are gonna die too he basically sees that
that they fight it's more than just a
mission to take them out it will be a
war and he actually suggests the plan
identical terrible at first which was
just kidnapped negan to start with i
love the reaction and you're linking
gives when Morgan start speaking up
about not killing like he had this look
of like just a pure annoyed but trying
to keep your [ __ ] together still with
him but that monologue that story that
Rick shares about the rock that was in
the middle of the roads at the King
place there it was a great moment
because as a viewer you really feel like
okay this is going to be the scene when
Ezekiel goes
or I will fight with you but vainly I
love that story because i love the
lesson to it and i feel like this story
was told so well by andrew lincoln that
i'll remember that story forever and be
able to share that with my
great-grandchildren excited i did enjoy
the same with the kids benjamin the dude
who's part of the kingdom was learning
to stand up to walkers where he bumps
into carol in the wood because i do feel
that Carol will eventually fight
alongside Rick's group again but they're
building that up they've been doesn't
enough for a while now but they're still
building up can't give all the
redemption in one episode but I feel
like they're teasing it against that
interaction where Benjamin has a later
scene with Ezekiel where he's basically
saying that after speaking with Carol he
sees like Rick's people feel the way
they do and that's what motivates
Benjamin to be like we should probably
help out Rick kind of look what happened
to Carol now the moment when Ezekiel
sellsword that they won't quite as part
of this episode strength as well cuz
like i said this episode does a great
job at tugging and feeling of hope so
while it sucks to hear that i feel that
something will change where zekiel
people will probably have to step up to
the plate because you know there's that
great moment where Ezekiel offers to let
Darrell hide inside the kingdom because
the Savior's don't step foot inside but
Darrell call them out saying how long do
you think that'll last I'm thinking it
was going to be a time of the Savior
step on it but that shot where darrell
has to you know come to terms that he's
being left behind from Rick's group
again because he has to hide out at the
kingdom that was a really heartbreaking
moment Darrell already has to be
stripped away from the group and you
could feel that fear and Daryl's eyes of
just not being with his family
especially if something goes wrong with
the Rickster if he's not going to be
able to be there to help them out I even
did like that little touch of what Sasha
is venting to Rosita about her
frustrations towards addy keel not
helping them out where then Rosita
brushes her off because when sasha was
venting i was thinking i don't feel like
in real life meaning i know this is like
apocalyptic show and everything but I
don't feel like Rosita would suddenly be
like friends with Sasha so when rosina
basically told her to go [ __ ] off I
thought it was a great touch because it
felt really in tune with how these
characters they hate Sasha probably
feels like her and Rosita both have
something in common because they lost
the man they love but you know Rosita
wasn't with Abraham because sasha took
him
at least in her eyes you know but the
most intense scene I think this thing
that everyone's going to be raving about
is the scene with the chain the row that
took place on the highway because prior
to the walkers showing up the show has
already done a great job of making it
feel like the Savior's have an eye on
everything at all times all right so
when they go to the cars that are
blocking the road they have to move them
and justin s my moment where they have
to move the cars you're already like oh
my god you better make this quick but
the show continues its strength of tug
and pull at hope they get to this row
that's chain out of the exact we refer
this cable it's like oh this is bad and
there's a bunch of explosives there and
they don't have any [ __ ] weapons so
they're like we need to take these
weapons so we get that feel enough up
all right we got some explosives now
when we need to hurry up because now
there's walkers on the way they hear on
the walkie talkie that negan is sending
people back to Alexandria to look for
Daryl so they need to hurry the [ __ ] up
but as it was playing out and the horde
was getting closer and I mean Andrew
Lincoln's intensity is one of my
favorite things of this show is back
actor there's way more recognition for
his work on this show i'm talking like
Golden Globe status or television he
deserves to be more recognized for the
[ __ ] work he put on this show because
on the Walker start coming Karl and the
others are trying to like get the cars
back then arrange to block the way and
it's all going so fast and it's so
suspenseful I didn't exactly know what
Rick was planning to do with the cars
all I heard him really say was when I
wave my hand down we'll do it the cables
between them and they just start plowing
down a bunch of walkers that was one of
the coolest moment of the entire series
it was like yes this is the [ __ ]
Walking Dead that I was hoping we get
back to this shows really given us the
redemption now even though that's
happening to the Savior's it's a good
symbolism of them fighting for survival
because after they mow them all down
they get back in the van Rycke still
like coming off of the you know the fear
and the suspense and they almost died
but Michonne is like we made it we're
gonna make it interracial love is so
beautiful in the chef's the Savior's
return to Alexandria looking for Daryl
they just start breaking [ __ ] which gets
on my nerves because they constantly
there's a series of shots of them
breaking stuff I'm like why do they have
to be this big
dicks I mean yeah that's the fact that
savers I'll [ __ ] deserve it died
bunch of dicks they're just like
knocking over tables and plates I'm like
Gerald not hiding underneath that small
table why are you knocking it over I
really like that actor who was leading
the Savior's into alexandria that day I
called negan chin here think of the
actual characters name of Simon I don't
know his character is but it feels like
he could be like a relative of Jeffrey
Dean Morgan there's also a very touching
scene with Aaron and his boyfriend whose
name I can't remember but Aaron is this
interesting character that I feel keeps
teetering on the line of they're going
to kill them up they're not going to
kill them off we don't want to get too
close to air and because you might not
be killing off later but then they kind
of just building up air and more and
more each season because he's that
character who can you can feel the fear
like he's a fearful guy but he acts
always always acts off courage always
asks off what is right and that exchange
between him and his boyfriend was really
touching moments like that make me go
are they gonna kill off Aaron because
his boyfriend was very much against him
having to go out there and look for
Gabriel once they discover that Gabriel
stole all the [ __ ] so like are they
setting this up so we can feel really
heartbroken when Aaron dies but beyond
the cable same one that are all mowing
down those walkers my favorite moment of
the episode where its final moment does
it discover that Gabriel serve alcohol
verse applies bringing us that feeling a
lack of hope so when they go looking for
Gabriel they start tracking him at least
in this intense scene where Rick and the
people that are with him are suddenly
surrounded by a large horde of men and
women all armed with all kinds of
weapons and when they're all surrounding
them I understood the group's initial
fearful reaction but as a viewer I was
watching it going like oh well these
guys are going to be people that Rick
probably recruits and they're all going
to fight the Savior's again so they have
these great shots where it's kind of
scary because they're outnumbered in the
group that we love is scared we don't
know what these guys are gonna do their
hands on this wonderful shot this
wonderful shot where Rick realizes what
the audience knows he found what he
needed people that can fight so one of
the rarest moments of the show he goes
from intense to joyful like I've seen I
don't think I've ever seen Rick smile
with such glee like that in this show
I think it's a moment that for fans of
the show especially people who really
love Rick they're not going to forget
that smile that red gay so oh no I'm
super happy this show is back I can't
wait to see how the rest of the season
unfold and something tells me that when
this season is done I might mark it down
as being one of the better seasons of
The Walking Dead you're new to the
channel you can subscribe at the real
rejects follow me at the Greg ALB on
Instagram and Twitter he goes to follow
at the real rejects on Twitter and shout
out again to eaglemoss collections for
these awesome toys is sent over tonight
and Keynote evil they have awesome
shirts there you've got to go check
these [ __ ] out